but i'm saying i have to go pull that
sword out the stone
this is farter
kanye west quoting a cinematic battle
cry
this is sparta
right before promising to unleash the
monster this is like not a joke yeah
this looks pretty serious
amid the rapper's very public dispute
with the gap he's sharing his
impassioned speech to the easy office
that's insane
that's insane yay kicks off the rant by
comparing the company to the movie 300s
ancient city
this is sparta
this is farter
yeah he's a fan of the movie
like the romans this is not celebrity
marketing
this is not a collaboration this is a
life
mission and just
take over
the globe
this comes as kanye takes shot after
shot at the beloved mall brand on
instagram
earlier this week he shared this pic of
reflective sunglasses writing in the
caption gap held a meeting about me
without me
this
is
the moment there will never be an
opportunity
with a guy like me that cares this much
about specifically this brand and has
done this up to this point
yeah he wasn't done throwing out some
famous comparisons we are you know like
tom brady and we're the football team
this is our football team and i'm
actually the tom brady because then you
can charge
four thousand dollars for a t-shirt but
i'm saying i have to go pull that sword
out the stone
you either believe me
kanye followed this up by sharing a
scene from the movie pool hall junkies
because every once in a while
the lion has to show the jackals
who he is next to christopher walken's
monologue he wrote the monster's about
to come alive again i'm fighting for a
position
to be able to change clothing and bring
the best design to the people this all
comes in the aftermath of some other
kanye backlash people questioning why
his designs are displayed in trash bags
at the stores look man
i'm an innovator
and i'm not here to sit up and apologize
about my ideas
that's exactly what the media tries to
do
makers apologize for any idea that
doesn't fall under
exactly
the way they want us to think but we
know kanye still got a fan in ex kim
kardashian who showed her support on the
gram just do something for my heart the
beauty mogul did just that snapping
these picks with their daughters north
in chicago west to promote yay's
futuristic sunglass launch last month
as for kim and kanye's relationship
we've learned things are cordial between
them as they begin to finalize their
divorce
you just gotta roll with it
according to e.t source being a great
dad has always been very important to
kanye and his main goal is to keep his
children happy
[Music]
you